all right so this is gonna be the
30-second version if you want more
detail check out the next video where
I'll be spending seven or eight minutes
really diving into how I use dev tools
to make changes the meta tag looks like
this copy and paste this line into the
head of your HTML and you are good to go
in order to make everything display in a
single column I needed to make it take
up the full viewport the basic idea is
that I ran through the CSS looking for
any containers with fixed widths set
smaller than 100% then I simply made
them 100% using a relative width of 100%
means that an element is going to take
up as much space as it can which means
that if you've got a container it'll
take up the full viewport tap targets
that's easy just add some padding to all
of your a tags
I used 1.5 m and after that I tested and
here it is on mobile and here it is when
the screen gets wider notice that
everything is taking up the full
viewport now if you want the full story
of how this happened
watch the next video